foreign
dear Lord
look at this guy
the sculpted Miracle of a man
is Brian Johnson the very moneyed former
owner of venmo
who literally looks younger every
passing day I consider myself to be a
professional Rejuvenation athlete
the speed at which I'm aging is less
than a 10 year old
I spend millions of dollars a year I do
over a hundred Therapies in any given
day
[Music]
what Brian really wants is to be 18
Again
and of course so do I
we just seem to be going about it in
very different ways
I try to get perfectly
[Music]
I ate 70 pounds of vegetables
I work out an hour a day
[Music]
the science is still unclear as to which
of us will hit the Fountain of Youth
first
but the former utahn thinks part of the
answer lies within his newly claimed
City I love this place when I was
looking for where to live next I mapped
out a few big cities in the U.S and I
wanted to find something where you could
do and say and be anything you wanted
and people a lot of times think about La
Hollywood first I think most people will
be surprised that there's like all this
other stuff going on here there's this
huge invisible world
thank you
[Music]
Los Angeles first called to me when I
was 18.
I arrived here at the spectacular Pomona
College
where I was a
[Music]
philosophy mate
I'm often asked what does the philosophy
major do
well I do the only thing I can do which
is Show you people that can do
[Music]
LA's thing has always been that anything
is possible here
away from Hollywood Fame it's a city
rich with car culture
Aerospace dreams and industrial
factories
this is the LA that I love
and while you may not know it La is in
the midst of turning into the most
interesting manufacturing Hub in the
world
oh
to begin our journey into this metallic
underworld let me show you Walden Speed
Shop
and it's proprietor Bobby Walden
he's part of LA's manufacturing Legacy
it's been in the metal shaping industry
for 35 years building and fixing vintage
car parts the old school way
by hand
metal shaping is an extremely old craft
but the thing holds true even from
hundreds of years ago to now there's
only three things you can do to metal
and that's shrink it and stretch it and
form it which is kind of folding other
than that there's really no new
technology
I really cut my teeth making
Harley-Davidson body parts from scratch
and then the hot rods started working on
those and chopping tops and building
panels and fixing rust
then start building pieces of bodies and
eventually became building an entire
body from scratch
if you're going to do what Bobby does
Southern California is the place to do
it
cool thing about Southern California
first off is the weather
back in the 40s after World War II the
guys came back now these guys are kids
still and they have lived a life and
seen things that we can't even imagine
today
and they come back they're alive they're
vibrant and they want Thrills right the
first thing is they start with the cars
they were cruising everywhere and then
they were probably 10 drag strips around
here you could drag race every day of
the week except for like Tuesday and
Wednesday
foreign
it was 50 mercuries and the crazy custom
cars
because of the Aerospace industry that
was out here it was a lot of available
material that you couldn't get anywhere
else in the country
the cars kept progressing and getting
better and better and better and better
you know
Los Angeles at one time there were
thousands of shops that did pattern
making small casting shops and all these
Artisans unbelievably gifted and
talented men and women
But as time evolved and Manufacturing
started being sent overseas and
automation came into play then these
skills and these jobs and these shops
got swallowed up and lost yeah if the
trade or the skill isn't taught
and perpetuated forward then we go back
we regress
[Music]
Bobby offered to show me every Twist
Bang and clang that goes into making a
simple metal Bowl
if we're going to make a bowl obviously
this thing has to curl up
so it has to be shrunk
he is a patient teacher but it's real
simple that gives you a tuck so we kind
of twist them back and forth yeah squish
it like that
and then go back the other way
is this a disaster no such thing
[Laughter]
all right all right
and now you go back in here and you
flatten these pooches out okay
this isn't a glamorous thing that I do
it's hard work
it's cold in the winter and it's hot in
the summer and it's loud all the time
[Music]
when you go home at the end of the day
you are tired
[Music]
if only we had a robot that could pick
up some of that and pick up the slack
you know and something you could like
scan something and it can memorize it
keep the dimensions and all that stuff
maybe one day maybe one day yeah
meanwhile across town that very same day
[Music]
I'm told that a group of robots is
sometimes known as a colony
[Music]
in this colony of robots belongs to
Machina labs and its co-founder and CEO
Ed Mayer
these are the sheet metal bending Ultra
Modern successors to folks like Bobby
Walden Chima was the biggest metal
process sector out of all the metal
processing pretty much most of the parcc
day today are sheet metal Parts you're
driving at a freeway you're kind of see
how she met all you're sitting in an
airplane spacing a sheet metal can
they don't really have a very agile
solution to make these parts they all
basically have to build a factory for it
before you can get your first batch of
parts
factories that produce large metal Parts
like car doors or airplane Wings can be
the size of a football field and three
stories high
huge very intricate and not at all
adaptable this is just a common problem
manufacturing that a lot of factories
are specifically built for the products
they're trying to manufacture and the
moment you want to change your design
you want to change your material you
have to almost build another Factory
so what we're trying to do at Mark you
know really is can we have that
overarching automation that is not
process specific it's a platform that
allows the robot to go pick up the right
tool and apply to the material so they
can get the right part the same way it
crafts under a blacksmith used to do
these parts
[Music]
have the skills to make fancy new shapes
and old ones that are too challenging
for other companies to make today
I know a lot of the stuff you work on
has got a top secret can we talk about
all these things yeah
this was an interesting one yeah it's
actually a composite mold for a drone
Wing okay so they basically lay up
composite on top of this and then they
put in a vacuum bag and put it in a
furnace and then they get a composite
part out of it
is this your donut operation yeah I know
giant Donuts this is actually like
toroidal tanks is one of the most good
designs for like you know satellites
tanks okay well like a like a fuel tank
or fuel tank okay one of the challenges
with these is that it's very hard to
manufacture back in the 60s actually
NASA used to make these things and they
mostly relied on basically uh talented
uh individuals people who've like lost
the knowledge so we're kind of working
with NASA to revive some of these as
well
but even if you're not NASA just a
regular Joe or Jane metal fanatic you
too can hire a pair of these robots to
do your bidding
this is your mocking a starter pack if
you're a customer you get two robots and
you get this platform in the center that
holds the Metal Sheets that cost you
about 2.5 million dollars to get going
and then it's about learning this
process of orchestrating the robots
using Market as software and getting
going with these things
[Music]
to truly put these robots to the test I
had what's known in La as the engineer's
skin peel
this is step one of having your face
built by robot is to get this mug
scanned with a laser that's also mounted
on a robot it's not super dangerous it's
a Class 2 laser it's like one level
above a laser pointer probably want to
close your eyes when we do this
ready ready please tell it to be gentle
all right eyes closed three two one here
we go
after the laser well lasered my face the
resulting 3D file was sent to these two
fine workers
they set about making metal me each with
its own clearly defined role at each
point in time is basically one robot is
forming in the other what we call like a
support robot okay
so while one robot puts all its effort
into deforming the sheet of metal the
other robot makes sure that deformation
is only happening where they want it to
in this case on the indent increasingly
looking like someone I know
it's
[Music]
just like me
good job
and the robot generated wonders didn't
end there
it's Ashley we made a little piece for
you
kind of take as a souvenir from La is
awesome
I feel like the the Flavor Flav of robot
machinery
that is awesome man thank you I feel uh
I've made it
admiring my glorious metal bounty
[Music]
I couldn't help but Wonder
what is it about La that makes such
Innovation possible
every time I come to La it's this new
take on manufacturing and this way a lot
of it comes out of Aerospace but to me
it feels like if there is a
manufacturing Revolution taking place
where all this stuff works and we make
some kind of Step change to a new age it
feels like La is somehow ended up as the
epicenter of that is this like
coincidence or this had to be here no I
agree with you and honestly like
partially
it's because of a SpaceX
it's hard to talk about LA's
manufacturing scene without
acknowledging the Elon in the room
like just about everyone here doing
sci-fi building Ed used to work at
SpaceX the Aerospace giant located on
the outskirts of Los Angeles I think one
thing Elon did for the folks who went to
SpaceX was like you know really broke
that fear of testing with Hardware I was
like well why don't we just make
Hardware the same way you make software
yeah like why don't you just test it and
you know every two months three months
try something else
and a lot of folks who were exposed to
that I think got a little bit of
confidence there it was like okay yeah
no I can't put together a facility with
the 22 robots and just figure this out
yeah
next stop another former spacexer taking
manufacturing to the Stars
[Music]
when I was sitting at SpaceX working on
the plan for how we're going to colonize
Mars my brain kept coming back to over
and over again how are we going to make
things on Mars
we're not going to ship Billet and
machine it on Mars we'll want to make it
in situ while we're there
that also kind of planted the seed for
me to kind of go into the 3D printing
palich co-founder and CEO of freeform
wants to make building size 3D printers
with conveyor belts and assembly lines
and to do that they gotta have a crap
ton of lasers
the digital brains to coordinate them
all
he's working on a prototype
all right so this is the machine this is
it lovingly call it golden eye yeah
because of the lasers yes because the
lasers
[Music]
the lasers are what make metal 3D
printing possible heating up a metallic
powder and Welding each new layer to the
previous layer we have more lasers on a
system that's running right now while
we're talking than anyone in the world
okay let's have a look I just let me get
you a little uh can I have a stool
please my viewing stool the viewing
stool yeah
yeah it is crazy you can just see all
the lasers got to go it at once right
yeah all 18 should be going right now
it looks like something engineered by a
super villain so kill a secret agent all
too slowly
this machine represents a huge
breakthrough for 3D printing
it's much faster much cheaper and much
more precise than what has come before
it possibly gets 3D printing close to
being Mass manufacturing technology
there has been this belief for many
years that the only way to go faster is
to trade trade quality
the real problem is that the machines
today are for lack of a better word are
dumb
you pre-program instructions and then
you tell the machine to go do that you
just iterate on it until you get it
right and then don't change it what a
shame for a technology that shouldn't
care what the part is coming off the
machine right I mean the whole thing is
about creativity and Imagination exactly
limitlessness
freeform undumbs these Contraptions by
collecting information on what the
machine did and feeding that into a
neural network that can then learn how
to do it better next time a process that
requires an Unholy amount of information
it's actually kind of crazy the amount
of data we move here is like Rivals like
Netflix you know like the sheer
magnitude of data
all that data means freeform can make
insanely complex designs out of robust
metal
and eventually rocket engines car parts
and whatever it is they make on Mars
[Music]
at this point in my journey through Los
Angeles I was feeling that like any
other TV host in Hollywood I needed a
useless award for myself
so I had Eric print one up
for exploring Manufacturing in Los
Angeles and doing such an amazing job I
present to you the worldy
[Applause]
thank you so much
it's glorious
what's it made out of
metal
that's incredible thank you thank you
thank you
seeing what Marvels can be accomplished
without the touch of a human hand
I couldn't help but think of the Bobby
Walden's of the world the nerd in me
just likes the machines themselves and
seeing what comes out of them but like
none of this stuff comes with many jobs
so there is this like kind of hollow
feeling that that accompanies this even
if it's a huge success we're trying to
take the human out of the loop of the
process itself because humans aren't
good at that but we're going to need
lots of people to build these factories
we're going to need people to maintain
these factories computers cannot
substitute for human creativity it's
what we should be training people to do
to like deploy these Precision robotics
yeah and maintain these Precision
robotics you know not like vacuum powder
off a plate you know
buddy here we go let's go home
carrying around all this metal was
becoming a real drag
so I skipped across town for something a
bit lighter
sugar
at a company that's invented a whole new
way of making sweet treats
[Music]
super proud of this this is the current
3D printer we designed and built it from
scratch
you can see like it looks like a kind of
commercial kitchen equipment but it also
contains all of the processes that we're
familiar with with 3D printing
manages this dry powder which is starch
and sugar and then we've got a print
head over here which moves across and
actually prints the object
these 3D printers can go into any
commercial kitchen in the US and even
across the globe
very cool and I could just eat it yeah
I don't recommend eating that yeah
but yes everything is edible please
for the taste test so we have a nice
assortment of different things Chef
Jonathan walked me through the menu we
have dealer's Choice here okay I got
some chocolate covered sushis or maybe
something a little more refreshing like
our lime skull
just your classic skull that's your
classic Shakespearean skull
oh yeah you could taste the lime yeah
it's sweet but it's not as sweet as I
thought it was going to be it's like
more meringue-like in texture that is
what I was looking for yeah it's like a
meringue but sugar lab isn't limited to
sugar
as long as the food can be dehydrated
into powder the team can print it
matcha
think kimchi think sparkly stuff
we do a lot of uh drink drops
dissolvables that we put in our
cocktails wine champagne so use plunket
oh it's cool you get the color and you
get the Fizz I need to give it a little
stir it taste yeah
is it safe to drink this much glitter
yeah yeah it's totally food safe edible
glitter but there was more we have a
strawberry covered chocolate
and more here we got our never lasting
Gobstopper and more cranberry
Frankenstein one of our 90s bon bon
shells matcha Buddha for you hazy IPA
ganache bombard glitter salt or happy
little pencil bonbons we got our fun
Little Octopus my favorite boat drink
drops the Sparkles the green tea bonbons
but it's really good
the thing about La man is that the ideas
are so big you can do anything here you
can print things out of sugar you can
buy Twitter with your spare change you
can mine asteroids you can go to Mars
sugar Ashley is right
in this city the Galaxy is truly your
oyster
but how do you get there
welcome to LA traffic
[Applause]
well that's next time
[Music]